[Music]
this summer the sequel to the iconic and
now
25 year old space jam featuring michael
jordan will hit
theaters this time the sequel revolves
around nba superstar lebron james and
will make some changes compared to the
original
for the most part the animated click
around bugs bunny and the others will
appear unchanged
but individual characters have been
adapted to the spirit of the times
or have been removed altogether bugs
bunny's girlfriend lola for example who
was quite revealing in the original
is to be visually toned down a bit
director malcolm the elise said it was
particularly important not to sexualize
the character who is
well known from children's films in the
way that was still the case in 1996.
according to lead is politically
incorrect and inappropriate to put a
crop top on an animated bunny
instead in keeping with the spirit of
the times they want to promote the
portrayal of self-confident female
characters
more news regarding lola states that she
will be involved with the wonder woman
universe in the new space gem as lee
confirms
she hangs out with wonder woman's
amazons for example
furthermore the decision was made to
completely remove the skunk
pepe le pew this is in spite of the fact
that his scene was already shot in the
summer of 2019
under then director terence nance in
which pepe made a prominent appearance
as deadline has found out that scene
involved a female bartender who is quiet
and snared
touched and kissed by pepe after she
successfully pushes him away
pepe jokingly comments to his fellow
cartoonists that a restraining order has
already been filed against him from
earlier days after a new york times
columnist openly called pippi an
example of rape culture those
responsible warner thought the scene was
too risky
how do you view the whole thing are you
happy about lola's fresh look and the
removal of pepe
or do you feel the whole discussion is a
bit overdone and you would like to see
the old familiar characters back
let us know in the comments the expected
release date of space jam
a new legacy is july 16 2021
in 1995 robin williams made the jumanji
series world famous and helped it
achieve
cult status which continues to this day
after two modern interpretations in
recent years and more than 900 million
use dollars in box office revenue it's
therefore not surprising that the fourth
part
is now planned first clues to the plot
could already be seen in the credits of
jumanji the next level from 2019. in it
one could see how all the video game
avatars were pulled into the real world
which
opens up countless possibilities for the
new jumanji part producer hiram kasih
didn't reveal any more details to
comicbook.com in an interview
though he did announce big plans for the
new project
at least when asked if there were
already talks with the actors from the
recent parts gazia
gave an encouraging answer although this
is not yet
rock solid information of the return of
dwayne johnson jack black and the others
anything else is considered pretty
unlikely anyway an official release date
is not yet known at this early stage of
production but we suspect a release
towards the
end of next year nobody could have
expected this news in the past few days
because
out of nowhere james cameron's avatar
from 2009
is returning to movie theaters the
reason is a re-release on the huge
chinese cinema market as reported by the
hollywood reporter
the imax 3d version as well as the
regular 3d version will be shown
and the hope is that the vanishingly
small gap of just under 7 million us
dollars to the previously most
successful film
avengers end game will be reached and
perhaps even
surpassed up to now avengers and game
and avatar have been competing for the
title of the most successful film of all
time with 2.798 and 2.79 billion us
dollars respectively
however that'll most likely change in
the next few days
what do you think of this approach do
you care that avatar could soon be at
the top or are you happy about the
comeback against
marvel as avatar fans who pursued a
similar strategy back then
feel free to write us a comment down
below
after many film studios have looked
optimistically into the spring of 2021
according to variety universal pictures
is the first of the big five major
studios to decide to postpone its
announced films
in some cases quite severely the
long-awaited fast and furious nine is
the one least affected by this
here the release is only postponed by
about four weeks from the end of may
to june 25th 2021 paramount is pursuing
a different strategy with john
krasinski's a quiet place part 2. for
here they even decided to push
forward the theatrical release from
september to may 28th
the late summer slot will be given to
antoine fuqua's sci-fi blockbuster
infinite starring mark wahlberg dylan
o'brien and rupert friend
it will be released on september 24th
2021
unfortunately its minions the rise of
grew the hardest
because here it has been decided to
delay the release by almost a whole year
meaning that you will not be able to
watch the sequel to the extremely
successful first part before july 1
2022 as sony revealed on twitter a few
days ago an animated musical called
k-pop demon hunters is currently in
production
after south korean pop music gained a
lot of popularity in the last few years
it was actually only a question of time
until it would be also thematically
covered in movies behind the scenes
ninjago director maggie kang and with
dragon director chris apple hands will
be in charge
according to variety the plot will
revolve around the south korean girl
group who are secretly demon unders in
addition to their world famous tours
k-pop demon hunters will belong to the
action adventure genre is set to be set
in a colorful
animated world the script is currently
being written by hannah mcmakin and
daniel jimenez who are also known as
hanyo while oscar winner aaron warner is
serving as
producer we're looking forward to
further news an official release date is
unfortunately
not yet known at the start of january
tessa thompson already confirmed that
the comic michael b
jordan could take over the direction of
the upcoming creed 3.
until recently the responsible parties
were reluctant to say anything
but now it's clear the black panther
actor will indeed soon make his debut in
the director's chair
in a statement jordan shared that this
had always been his dream and that he'd
only been waiting for the right moment
he had the privilege to learn from
hollywood biggies such as ryan coogler
and denzel
washington and is now ready enough for
the next step however
that's not all as the long-awaited u.s
release date was also announced in the
process
and has been set for the thanksgiving
weekend at the end of november
2022 while there's no information about
the plot of cree 3 currently
one can look optimistically into the
coming weeks and months considering that
shooting is sure to start soon
[Music]